Reino Unido y otros 14 países de la
common West celebraron la coronación de
su Rey Carlos III por ejemplo este
sábado se convirtió en monarca de Canadá
el segundo país en importancia en Ottawa
a la capital las autoridades del país
también vivieron una ceremonia especial
desde nuestros comienzos como Colonia
francesa hasta hoy la monarquía ha sido
una parte integral de nuestras
instituciones y nuestra identidad
la sangre de nuestros corazones Envía un
canto de esperanza en reconocimiento a
Carlos III El rey de la commonwey
Carlos tercero es rey en nueve países de
América excepto Canadá y Belice el resto
son islas del Caribe donde hay un
movimiento republicano creciente el
último en cambiar de forma de estado fue
Barbados Jamaica aspira a ser el
siguiente allí la celebración fue vista
con apatía y también de forma
reivindicativa
todavía tenemos instituciones de la
esclavitud y la colonización con
nosotros hoy en 2023 y necesitamos hacer
mucho más por lo que esta eliminación
del Rey termina simbólicamente con esa
fase de nuestro viaje
Isabel II nunca dejó de mirar a América
de hecho su primer viaje internacional
en 1953 fue a Panamá 70 años después
Carlos III tendrá dos retos cultivar los
lazos con América y sobre todo mantener
la corona en los países donde este
sábado comienza a reinar
[Aplausos]